we've got the service in Parliament
today where we're going to give our
condolences to King Charles III on the
saddafism mother
and I think there's a sense of unity in
Parliament at the moment people are
coming together
in a combination of their grief and also
their gratitude to the queen for her
huge amazing service and you know the
condolence
messages we've had in Parliament during
the debate the tributes I think they've
been really heartfelt
cool
I've been saying to my guest this
morning when we first heard we were
shocked but not surprised and now that
shock is turning to reflections of her
the Queen's life absolutely I mean one
can't help but think of the times that
one has met or when we've seen him
everyone's talking about the Paddington
moment of course and the James Bond
moment when she made the whole nation
laugh and that was the great thing about
her she had this wonderful sense of
humor as well as that warmth and that
compassion as well as a sense of Duty so
um we are going to miss her very very
much
talk to me about later on this morning I
think it's about half past 10 when the
king and the queen consort will come
along to the Palace of Westminster it's
Westminster Hall isn't it quite poignant
that that particular part of the palace
well that's right
um uh the queen has often addressed both
houses of Parliament and Westminster
Hall on big state occasions a jubilee
event or the visit of a another head of
state
so it's a part of Westminster which is
resplendent with history
I think we'll be very proud uh proud of
our country
proud of our amazing monarchy but it
will also be a moment of reflection as
you said at the moment of great sadness
how difficult again I put this to
Anthony Selden earlier on today the
coronation we don't know when that will
be previously it was what 14 months
wasn't it between the queen knowing that
she would become Queen and then
subsequently being crowned
um do you think given the challenges
that the country is facing at the moment
that will have to be paired down
I I don't know I mean um I imagine
um uh the that's a big discussion at the
moment within the Royal household uh at
the moment though I think we're just
hugely grateful to the way King Charles
has has shown himself I mean he's
obviously must be hurting deeply at the
moment but he's had the amazing strength
to show that he is now The King and I
think the whole country is United behind
him
indeed so
um I was just I was reflect I was away
actually when the news broke and then I
saw images of you along with the other
leaders at the proclamation what was
that like
well it it has this dual feeling that
there's a sadness I mean when you're
seeing you're singing the National
Anthem you having to change what you've
been doing your whole life yeah so there
is that sadness there but there is that
huge Pride uh in our country uh and in
our new monarch uh and uh he he will be
unifying force just like his mother was
and that's that's so special about our
country
oh do you have a thought on on the
sporting events being canceled I mean
particularly the football
yeah I mean I think it's a tough
decision for everyone involved because
it's this mixed feeling isn't it there's
this desire to you know celebrate her
life by celebrating our country uh and
our sporting achievements whilst also
making sure you're being respectful from
the way that it is is right too so I
don't I don't envy the people who've had
to make those really tough decisions